they'd spend hours making the costume
the two young boys let's call them
Johnny and Max had always been on the
creative side sometimes they got teased
for it at school but they didn't care as
long as they had each other they could
handle anything they were best friends
maybe one day they'd build great things
together out of concrete and steel but
for now they worked with cardboard prior
projects had included building a rocket
out of cardboard in Johnny's backyard
like the kind that put a man on the moon
they'd also made a box Fort like no
other more a box Castle really the kind
that would stand for a hundred years as
long as it didn't rain of course but all
that felt like nothing compared to the
tunnel monster to these two young
friends it was a thing of beauty a fully
articulated cardboard monster costume
meticulously cobbled together from boxes
masking tape cardboard tubes for arms
and legs and a little twine to bring it
all together Frankenstein Dracula Freddy
Krueger those Silver Screen phonies were
nothing compared to the tunnel monster
they even cut out eye holes in the head
and Drew the scariest snarling mouth
that they could write below the making
was over and now they were ready to play
Johnny and Max took the costume down to
one of their favorite places in town the
abandoned Rector construction site to
many would seem like a strange and
dangerous place for two young children
to play but for Johnny and Max it was
perfect after all they were the age
where they had more imagination than
sense Max would be the one wearing the
costume Johnny helped him put it on
piece by piece using extra masking tape
and Twine where necessary to fasten all
the pieces together little by little Max
became the tunnel monster the
transformation was complete and it was
finally time for the games to begin
Johnny ran wielding a stick as a
defensive weapon while Max gave Chase he
could feel his own hot breath within the
cardboard mask it was oddly exhilarating
he gave a monstrous Roar and charged
after his friend chasing him into the
child-sized pipes of An Unfinished water
drainage system it was more fun than
anything they could have imagined Max
really got into his role he lunged
forwards grabbing Johnny with his
cardboard gauntlets and tried to drag
him back into the tunnel all while
giving low guttural growls Johnny
laughed and swatted at Max with his
stick like a night wielding a sword they
ran and crawled through the tunnels the
best of friends having the best of times
making the kind of memories that would
last forever and in that sense they were
right something they made that day would
echo on forever but it wouldn't be
something they would look back upon
fondly if they weren't so busy running
through the tunnels Max and Johnny might
have noticed that something was amiss
they might have seen that even though it
was only 3 P.M on a summer's day the sky
was beginning to darken it may not have
saved the them but it might have given
them time to prepare for what was coming
Max was still chasing Johnny down a pipe
still fully in character as the tunnel
monster his arms extended to grab his
fleeing friend while Johnny tripped Max
stopped to help him up but something was
wrong when Max helped Johnny stand up
Johnny instinctually pushed him away as
though it wasn't actually his friend
anymore Max stumbled backwards in shock
and horror he could feel something
changing beneath the cardboard he
suddenly was in pain this terrible pain
like he was being pulled apart and put
back together he started to scream it
was a horrible sound like nails on a
chalkboard Johnny had to hold his ears
as the screaming got louder and louder
but Max couldn't stop he was hurting too
much to stop Johnny was crying he didn't
know what was happening only that his
friend was in terrible pain and that
there was seemingly nothing he could do
to stop it even Max didn't know much
more than that but he thought it might
have something to do with the suit it
felt like it was full of fire ants
crawling and biting it felt like his
body was full of fire ants he needed to
take the suit off before it got any
worse but he couldn't the suit wouldn't
come off he reached for the cardboard
mask and tried to tug it off his head
but it wouldn't budge he felt like he
was tugging at the skin of his own face
he could suddenly feel everything that
brushed against the cardboard like it
was connected to his nerve endings the
fear in the Panic got worse and he kept
screaming it was a deafening ear
splitting screen he didn't know it but
anything electrical within a 200 meter
radius was dying TVs shut off radios
fizzled out cars stopped running nobody
who didn't work for the SCP Foundation
would ever know why it wasn't even 3 30
PM but the sky above looked black as
midnight Max was afraid but all he could
do was cling to the familiar he lunged
forwards and grabbed Johnny pulling him
into his trembling Embrace is he still
Max now no he doesn't think so anymore
he's something else entirely has he held
his friend Max tried to dig his fingers
into the mask and tear it off they
pierced through the cardboard tearing
holes into it it was agonizing but the
masks stayed put there was no Escape he
closed his eyes just for a moment maybe
it was a bad dream maybe he could make
it disappear but it didn't disappear
only he did Max was no more there was
only the tunnel monster when Johnny woke
up he was disoriented and afraid he was
in complete darkness but he could feel
the old metal of a rusty railroad track
beneath his feet he didn't remember how
he got there and he didn't remember Max
either not his face or even his name but
that's all right Max didn't remember him
either when the terrified Johnny
eventually found his way out of the old
railway tunnel he'd somehow found
himself Finn he was rescued by emergency
services and treated for dehydration
because of the incredibly strange
circumstances of his disappearance and
reappearance over four thousand
kilometers away it was only natural for
the SCP Foundation to check in but
seeing as Johnny had no memory of where
he was or who he was with prior to his
mysterious teleportation all they ever
did was investigate the tunnel he'd
appear in of course they didn't find a
thing the case was closed shortly
afterwards written off as a kind of
one-off spatial anomaly Johnny was given
amnestic treatment and reintegrated back
into his normal life he would never
remember his encounter with the tunnel
monster but many would for decades and
decades to come there would be stories
and Scattered witness accounts from all
kinds of people maintenance workers
doing electrical repairs on subway
tunnels sewer workers cleaning up
blockages in pipes Road workers fixing
the asphalt in underpass the challenge
with being an SCP Foundation field agent
is often separating the genuine leads
from the urban legends and spooky
stories but the details here were all
too similar and specific after all it
would be such a strange thing to make up
a moldy old pile of cardboard boxes
getting up and running towards you but
stranger still these incidents and
encounters were occurring all over the
United States with the only
commonalities being that all of them
happened in tunnels or tunnel-like
structures the foundation didn't know if
they were dealing with one entity or
many another peculiar Factor they
observed was that sometimes people who
had encounters with the tunnel monster
then themselves appear in tunnels
extremely far away from the ones in
which they first encountered it as far
as the foundation was aware besides
transporting them vast distances it
never actually harmed any of its victims
but according to one Boston sewer worker
Gus segrelia when the tunnel monster
laid its cardboard hand on him he felt
the most profound sense of paranoia and
drag he described it as feeling like a
thousand eyes in the dark watching you
die then he blinked and he woke up in an
Arizona Viaduct roughly six hours later
everyone who reported a similar
experience with the tunnel monster was
detained debriefed and given amnestics
by the foundation eventually they
gathered enough data on prior encounters
to accurately predict the next tunnel
that the tunnel monster would manifest
inside a new mobile task force was
formed to secure the creature MTF new
four also known as the box cutters what
they didn't expect was that when they
finally engaged the Beast was that it
was no larger than a human child it
wasn't some huge tunnel dwelling
nightmare even after all these decades
the tunnel monster was little more than
a frightened lonely little boy he
growled attempting and failing to come
off as intimidating to these hardcore
MTF members and referred to himself as
the tunnel monster when they didn't
react with fear and surprise like the
others he became subdued they were able
to peacefully apprehend him and take him
back to site 54 for testing and
containment preliminary x-rays found
that the cardboard costume hadn't just
fused with the boy it had completely
transformed him on the inside he was
filled with crude cardboard copies of
all the major internal organs with his
blood vessels and nerve endings made out
of colored pieces of string they
couldn't find any information on who the
boy was if he had ever been a boy at all
and he was given the designation
scp-3663 in order to find out more one
of the leading researchers on the
scp-3663 case researcher Doyle decided
to conduct an interview with the tunnel
monster it had been the only interview
with the creature to date due to the
emotional distress it caused the
creature when asked about its identity
it replied with only the tunnel monster
her when asked why it attacked and
teleported people to different locations
the creature replied the tunnel monster
captures people that's me I'm the tunnel
monster I capture people and take them
into the tunnels where I live in the
tunnels the pipes I'm the tunnel monster
has the interview progressed the tunnel
monster became increasingly upset until
it began weeping through its cardboard
face finally culminating with its crying
out between sobs please I don't want to
play anymore
scp-3663 only feels comfortable in
tunnels and will teleport away in
distress if confined anywhere else as
such its containment chamber is
technically the maintenance tunnels
underneath site 54 Where it seems to
have made a home for itself occasionally
if it experiences fear damage or stress
it may Dem manifest and appear in
tunnels elsewhere at that point the box
cutters are deployed to collect 3663
once again and bring him back to site
54. so far there has only been one major
Containment Breach with
scp-3663 but it was a little more deadly
than you might expect for a boy-sized
creature made of cardboard the tunnel
monster escaped from the site-54 tunnels
and began wailing in pain it went
positively berserk attacking surrounding
staff and trashing parts of the facility
anyone who heard the whales of the
tunnel monster reported becoming
extremely psychologically disturbed by
them during this four hour Rampage the
monster also tried multiple times to
destroy itself with various implements
but was unsuccessful after
scp-3663 was recontained two deceased
members of personnel were recovered from
the scene autopsies showed the cause of
death was a buildup of paper residue and
wood pulp in all of their major blood
vessels as well as sinuses ear tubes and
the majority of the digestive and
respiratory systems a number of other
staff members were found to have been
affected to a lesser degree but are
expected to make full recoveries what
triggered this explosive and deadly
Outburst not even the tunnel monster
itself knew the answer to this question
but we do at exactly the same time a 79
year old man passed away from natural
causes after what seemed like a
thoroughly unremarkable life that man's
name was Johnny now check out
scp-1762 where the dragons went and
scp-3999 I am at the center of
everything that happens to me for more
tragic and terrifying anomalies from SCP
explained